the blue sky. New directions to follow without hesitation. Pyro, the metropolis where Egyptians,
Greeks, Armenians, Turks, Jews and Syrians came together. A prosperous city through which caravans
passed on their way to Mecca, Damascus, Baghdad and of course those heading along the Nile to
Black Africa. Come closer, come closer. Two old hairs. Come closer, try it. This potion is the
remedy for all ills. A true miracle. Holy crap. Take it. Come closer and you will see how this
noble gentleman is cured in front of everyone. You have seen him. He is no longer green. What
was in here? Oh, the greatest of all Effendi's possessions. Hum. A wonderful medicine. Oil.
Sir. Your. Sir. Thank you. Sir. Yes. Your secretary is waiting for you in the drawing room.
So, according to Mr. Bruce, Lake Tana described by the Jesuit P would be the source.
Ah, James, a good walk. Interesting. Tell me, have you found porters to accompany us?
Yes, about 20, but it hasn't been easy. As soon as they heard about our destination,
they looked for porters. Yes, we are all very strong porters. I defended myself. I,
I am a porter. And where are you going, Effendi? Yes, where are you going?
We are going up the Nile to Abyssinia. The caravans never pass through Abyssinia. It is
normal for the porters to be afraid. Well, we don't want cowards on our expedition anyway,
but nothing will stop me from reaching the source of the Nile.
Ah, yes, the Nile, a great river with a great history.
Although the Egyptians worshipped the sun, it was the Nile that they owed their lives to.
460 years before our era, Herodotus already observed that the floods left fertile ground
on the plains. Egypt is a gift from the Nile and further towards the source.
Beyond Aswan, sir, waterfalls impede navigation. Beyond that lies the unknown.
Indeed, children, beyond Aswan lay Nubia. That was the unknown, the mystery.
Then, Master, Bruce discovered the source of the Nile.
Oh, James Bruce was a case in point. A Scottish aristocrat who traveled in search of difficult
challenges. He thought the source of the Nile was in Abyssinia, today Ethiopia.
Master, on your map the source of the Nile is much further south.
Oh, yes. Today we know that there are two sources, but Bruce had no precise map.
That man did not hesitate. He was not afraid. And he had better have been,
since he had to overcome many obstacles. So, leaving Egypt, Bruce headed for the Red Sea.
Yasin, are you going to tell all the men who are not working to hide, to disappear?
There are almost more pirates than fish in the Red Sea. And I have a surprise for those who want
to bother us. By the way, you are going to distribute this among the men. Yeah, and this
is for you. Listen, this is what we're gonna do. If we run into any pirates, you're gonna
do you want to come james let's get a closer look there's no doubt about it they're pirates
let's get them close what a beautiful catch there's very few of them it's gonna be easy
boys prepare to board to mount the attack and surprise them you're gonna stay behind the rail
until the last moment it's a little pirate trick that always works got it what a ruse how clever
of you, boss. Day alert. Ready. Board. Now fire. Come on. Yassi, it's your turn. Get up. Huh? Oh,
no. Not that. Not that. This is getting worse and worse. Bravo, boys. Good fishing. The last
ones. Help. Masabar. We gotta be careful. It's a dangerous region. And now heading southwest
towards those mountains. Drugs. Drugs. Bandits. They're giving us the runaround again. Welcome
to Masaba, noble travelers. We offer you our hospitality. No, thank you. We are in a hurry.
Think you should not refuse our hospitality. Better to cooperate or dissimulate. I do not
like them. Good. Let's go. Ah. Now tell me, gentlemen, what are you doing here? My name is
James Bruce and this is my private secretary, Luigi Bellagani. I am a British subject. These
are my letters of introduction from the King of England, the Sultan of Constantinople, Cairo and
Mecca. What have you come for? Are you far from home? I am interested in geography, sir, and in
my country very little is known about yours. I have orders not to let foreigners pass, but my
king may be curious to see Europeans. You do not happen to be a doctor. They need one in the royal
palace in Gondar. As you can see, my friend, fate smiles on the bold. I am a doctor and I am ready
to assist your king. I wish you a safe journey, gentlemen. My trusted man, Tabaru, will accompany
you. Oh, oh, and I can't take it anymore. Do you realize, Luigi? We are contemplating the unknown.
For centuries, these mountains have isolated Vizinha. There is talk of mysteries, even spells.
It's extraordinary. After three weeks of walking, they reached Dua, the first city on the route.
What a shame. Look, here, do you know why we locked them up? It's very simple. That way their
families have to pay the king to free them. A strange way of making them pay taxes. And on the
Right, you can see the obelisks of Axum.
But what are they doing?
Oh, oh, nothing.
They're just hungry.
But they don't plan on eating that raw meat.
It seems so, Luigi.
Thank you.
Mmm, it's good.
Even exquisite and very fresh.
Do you want to try it?
Apparently, the Avicinians were the inventors of stick tartar and carpaccio.
The piece we're running away from is very dangerous.
Locke.
Moe.
Aleka.
He says we can't go this way, that we must leave immediately.
But that is a pledge we have to leave them our belongings.
No, I'm starting to get fed up.
This is blackmail.
Tell those low-life bandits that they're the ones who are going to leave.
Straight back where they came from.
What is this earring?
In my country, earrings are worn in the ears.
Here like this.
Oh.
Do you want me to show you European fashion?
I knew it would impress, but not so much.
Look.
Quickly, everyone against the rocks.
We must protect ourselves.
Move.
Nose rings, men fleeing because of the flies.
It's a curious country.
Gondar.
We've been walking for 95 days.
That's not our destination yet.
Don't forget that what interests me is the source of the Nile and it must surely be there.
Now we have to go to the palace so you can be introduced.
Lewis.
But this is a village, not the capital.
My glasses, my glasses.
Emperor Amonud is not here.
The Queen Mother will receive you.
It is very luxurious.
Unbelievable.
Come closer.
So you are the doctor?
Yes, madam.
Is there anyone sick here in the palace?
I am Iteg, the queen mother.
The king is away.
A terrible illness threatens my little ones.
Follow me.
Come in.
Can you save them?
Berylina, Luigi, go get my bag with the medicines and have some water heated.
Ah, oh, doctor, it was a miracle.
God sent you.
My son is still fighting.
His vizier Rasmichel is constantly urging him to do so.
He could not bear to lose these.
Aye. No. Always more violence. Do you see those red ribbons on the spears? Each one means an
enemy killed in battle. And all because of that man. You will meet him soon. Dr. James Bruce and
his secretary, Mr. Bellagani. We must kneel and kiss the emperor's foot. It is the custom.
No way. You are a scoundrel. Greetings, great emperor of Abyssinia and Subisir. I have come
from a long way to see Lake Tana. I am looking for the source of the Nile, and I am certain that
it is there. No one would go to such trouble just to see a lake. Either you are mad or you are lying.
He must be a spy. Calm down, Razmel. This man saved my children. I answer for his actions.
Um, foreigners, you are our guests. Tonight we will celebrate our victory. Was telling you that
I would be very pleased to go to Lake Tana, for we are at war there with the Gialas. Only our
warriors are allowed to go. If you will allow me, tomorrow at dawn I will show you what they call
a warrior in my country, and you are all invited to the spectacle. Ladies and gentlemen, your
highnesses, Grand Vizier, watch what you are about to see. How awful. How awful. Proving yourself to
be a great warrior. You will accompany us on the next expedition to Lake Taro. Thank you, sir.
This land is ours. Get out. These are the terrible guides. Who is that clown? That man is crazy.
Attack. Attack them. Listen to me. Brave men. Warriors, you are brave soldiers and the world
knows about your exploits. I also respect you and wish you well, but I have been trying to reach Lake
Tana for two years and I would not like you to stop me. He is crazy. He wants to go to the lake.
I am here with my army to fight and he tells me about a lake. He is crazy. Yes, chief, he is crazy
and it is dangerous, chief. I do not mean just any lake, but the one at the source of the Nile.
Fight at once. I order you to fight. Come on. After all, war is foolish. That is true. What do
we gain by fighting. We will promote tourism. It could work with the lake. You, bunch of useless
bums. Do you want to go back? If they do not want to fight, neither do we. That Bruce is incredible.
We turn around. Hey, James, wait up. Finally. Listen, that's where the waterfall where the
lake empties must be. Yes, there it is. I found it. I found it. The waterfall of Tezat,
the source of the Nile. Ah, it's only natural that he should be happy after all his efforts.
Yes, but two great disappointments awaited him.
To begin with, when he descended the river to reach Egypt,
Bruce realized that another tributary fed into the Nile at Khartoum.
He only discovered one of the sources of the Nile, that of the Blue Nile.
It would be almost 100 years before he discovered the White Nile.
And what was the second disappointment, Master?
Well, Europe was not prepared for his story.
When he returned to England, Bruce published his adventures.
But no one believed those stories of bloodthirsty emperors, hippos and eating raw meat.
but in France, a young Corsican general who was preparing to invade Egypt paid much more
attention to the information contained in Bruce's book. Ah, this is really interesting.
In the 19th century, a new generation of more educated explorers would take inspiration from
Bruce and begin the golden age of exploration in Africa. Barden and Speak would reach the source
of the White Nile at Lake Victoria. A German bar would venture into Sudan and there would be more
like Livingston, the great explorer and missionary. But that's another story. Let's explore the
corners of our ever-changing world.
Finding paths to chart, always taking a step further and never giving up.
More for the good of humanity.